[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
guilty that's the verdict for r kelly
women's rights attorney gloria allred
gives us her take on the jury's
monumental decision plus remembering
gabby petito our focus is still on
morning gabby and honoring gabby as a
petito family mourns a life cut short
the fbi manhunt targets brian laundry
and a look inside the relationship of
former billionaire elizabeth holmes and
sonny bowani what personal text messages
were on display in her federal trial and
later these are
injuries that are essentially invariably
fatal the medical examiner takes the
stand in the mennonite murder trial law
on crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin it's a guilty verdict for r kelly
after months in federal court for years
worth of sex crimes this as sexual
assault advocates and women's rights
attorney alike applaud the verdict
on monday a federal jury found r kelly
guilty on all counts charging him with
sex trafficking and racketeering crimes
the trial stretching close to six weeks
with testimony from 50 witnesses many
who are victims of kelly's sexual abuse
most of the victims under the age of 18
at the times of the crimes
victims provided traumatic testimony
recounting that kelly knowingly
transmitted herpes to some others say he
locked them in a room without food or
water for days on end one woman
testified to when kelly beat her with a
shoe and forced her to get an abortion
even two john does testified that they
too were sexually abused by kelly the
jury deliberated for just nine hours in
the case kelly now faces life in prison
and additional charges in illinois and
minnesota
we're joined by fame women's rights
attorney gloria allred who represents
some of the victims in r kelly's trial
gloria thanks for being with us
thanks for inviting me brian always a
pleasure now gloria you've said of all
the high-profile cases you've taken on r
kelly was the worst offender of all more
so than even harvey weinstein what sets
him apart from the rest and makes him in
your eyes worst of all
well first of all he took advantage of
vulnerable underage girls and he used
his fame to lure them in
and of course he also had his powerful
business empire to enable and support
him because many people in his inner
circle
assisted him in recruiting these
underage girls and then victimizing them
and as you just mentioned
he also
had genital herpes he knew that he had
this sexually transmitted disease but
despite the fact that he knew it he did
not disclose it uh to uh at least
the individuals that i represent
and further he did not use a condom
which would have lessened the risk of
transmission of the disease as a result
many of the underage girls are left with
a lifetime of suffering from genital
herpes and finally
he had his rules and he punished these
women if they did not obey every rule or
disobeyed any rule
and he also required many of them to
engage in child pornography with him so
he is so horrific that he would take
under age girls and he directed and he
produced uh this child pornography and
then often he would use it not only for
his sexual pleasure to watch it but to
use it to threaten them that if he ever
told anything about him
to anyone if they ever did that he would
release some of these humiliating and
shameful videos
quite the list there this case was a
huge win in terms of the metoo movement
and women's rights what could this
verdict mean for future cases and do you
think it could encourage more women to
come forward
i do think that it sends a message to
other high-profile predators that they
are not above the law and that if they
victimize
underage girls or adults in the way that
kelly did and he had a plan he had a
scheme he manipulated them
that uh you know even though he tried to
control them that women are not going to
be controlled and when these women broke
free as many of my clients did
they found their power they found their
courage and they decided after they
contacted me that they did want to speak
to law enforcement and that was an
option for them and i'm so proud of them
that they were willing to testify at
trial
three of the five victims for whom
charges were filed uh testified at the
trial and three those three were my
clients uh the other two who testified
were not of course the sixth victim for
whom charges were fought as aaliyah
and uh she is deceased so she couldn't
testify but i had another witness who
testified about seeing her in abuse of
sexual conduct
uh uh by r kelly with her so um you know
it took a lot of courage because they
had to undergo intense
cross-examination but they survived it
and that's how this verdict was won and
i think the federal prosecutors did a
great job homeland security did an
exceptional job
so uh that's how it you know it's not
just times up because i've been doing
uh you know this for 47 years we've been
the leading women's rights victims
rights law firm in the nation and women
have had the courage over those 47 years
do exactly what my clients did testify
in criminal cases sometimes no criminal
case but they file a civil lawsuit
against the predator sometimes we did
confidential settlements without any
lawsuit with the predator and so you
know let's not underestimate the courage
of women but i think that's the problem
for powerful men whether they're in the
music industry the entertainment
industry sports business religious world
whatever
these victims may have the last word in
this case they did thank you very much
for that gloria allred and all the work
you've done not only in this case but in
past and future cases
thank you very much great to be with you
thank you and now to florida where the
parkland shooter is set to stand trial
but for a crime unrelated to the school
shooting
nicholas cruz is charged with 34 counts
of premeditated and attempted murder for
the 2018 shooting at marjory stoneman
douglas high school in parkland florida
17 students and staff were killed in the
shooting while a trial date has not yet
been set for that crime cruz now faces
additional charges for attacking a
detention deputy in a broward county
jail back in 2018. in a hearing on
tuesday the defense argued that not all
audio and video of the incident was
preserved and therefore the trial should
be dismissed cruz is charged with
battery of a law enforcement officer
that trial is set to begin on monday
still ahead on law and crime daily the
mennonite murder trial a u.s airman
faces a hefty prison sentence after a
young mennonite woman is brutally killed
but first the family of gabby potido has
a message for brian laundry the latest
on the fbi manhunt and more after this
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
youtubetv today and then locate law and
crime in the channel guide and for only
1.99 a month you can add the network to
your bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily two
weeks that's how long it's been since
anyone has seen or heard from brian
laundry new information though shows
laundry was camping with his family just
days after gabby petitto was found
killed
authorities say petito was killed in
late august her remains were found in
mid-september on september 1st brian
laundry returned to his family home in
florida without potato the la joe family
attorney now confirms brian and his
family were camping in east central
florida between september 6th and 8th
all this as the fbi manhunt for laundry
ramps up basing the search on
intelligence and dna matching the fbi
has also obtained surveillance video
from the campsite area authorities have
not explicitly linked him to potato's
death but have issued a federal warrant
for his arrest in relation to illegally
using another person's debit card
meanwhile gabby petito's family issued a
plea for brian laundry to give himself
up law and crime's angela levy has more
in the search for laundry and the ways
petito's family is honoring her
we actually got behind a car yesterday
and there was a wyoming sticker
and the letters were gbz cubs
she's with us
she's with us gabby petito's mom nicole
breaking down as she talks about the
signs she sees that gabby is still with
her
our focus is still on
morning gabby and honoring gabby the
family displayed let it be tattoos they
got in gabby's memory the same tattoo
she had and they're setting up the gabby
potito foundation to help the families
of missing people
a plea from gabby's dad
i want to ask everyone to help
all the people
that are missing and need help and like
i said before
it's on all of you
everyone that's in this room
to do that
and if you don't do that for other
people that are missing that's a shame
the fbi is searching for brian laundry
named a person of interest in gabby
petito's disappearance reality tv star
dog the bounty hunter joined the search
and said he received information that
laundry and his parents camped at
florida's fort de soto park after he
returned from wyoming without gabby
petito the attorney for laundry's
parents confirms they camped with brian
and left the park together but denies
the parents are helping their son evade
police and said the fbi is aware of the
camping trip steve bertolino told one
reporter dog was spewing bologna but
bertolino told law and crime i will no
longer give that dog credibility or
dignify his false claims with the time
of my reply
the lawyer for the petito family has a
message for brian laundry the laundries
did not help us find gabby there sure is
not going to help us find brian
for brian
we're asking you to turn yourself in
to the fbi or the nearest law
enforcement agency gabby petito's family
thanked law enforcement and all the
people who helped them search for gabby
in wyoming their attorney also said they
are 100 happy with the fbi's
investigation so far for law and crime
daily i'm angenette levy
joining us today is legal analyst dina
doll and terry austin dina with an
arrest warrant out for laundry not for
potato's death but for using someone
else's debit card if the fbi does find
him could they even hold him for a long
time based on what info they have
you know i'm i think the reason why
we're seeing the
warrant for the bank cards is because
it's much easier at this point for them
to have to prove but that doesn't mean
that they wouldn't have enough evidence
to also issue a warrant for her murder
it was ruled a homicide we don't know
everything the fbi knows but they don't
need to play that hand right now
if they have them in custody and they
need to keep him they could issue most
likely the warrant for that and keep
them longer makes sense terry why do you
think there's a delay in connecting
potato's cause of death to something or
someone
you know brian it's difficult to
determine the cause of death if the body
has been exposed to heat and the
elements and we know for a fact that
brian came back on september 1. so even
assuming from that date her body was
found on september 19th that's a couple
of weeks it would be very difficult to
get evidence from a body that would be
that decomposed the other thing is that
there are multiple areas where the crime
might have occurred like the van and the
forest or the desert where she was found
all right so still a lot of information
and evidence to be collected to finally
pinpoint what if anything happened and
of course where is brian laundry thank
you both coming up on law and crime
daily the medical examiner takes the
stand in the trial of a u.s airman mark
gooch plus a look inside the intimate
relationship of elizabeth holmes and
sonny bowani the latest in her federal
trial after the break
[Music]
welcome back personal text messages come
to light in the federal trial of
elizabeth holmes on tuesday jurors saw
the back and forth between holmes and
former romantic partner ramesh sunny
balwani
the texts show the pair collected
upwards of 250 million dollars from
investors including rupert murdoch just
days after a lab director quit due to
compliance issues but wani replied to
the text quote they are not investing in
our company they are investing in our
destiny former theron's lab director
adam rosendorf testifying he felt
theranose higher-ups would not provide
resources needed for proficiency tests
founded back in 2003 holmes claimed the
now-defunct theranos would revolutionize
blood testing later investigations found
many issues with its programs the former
billionaire faces 12 fraud charges in
connection to her time with the company
let's bring back legal analyst dina dahl
and co-host terry austin terry how
damning are these text messages and do
they rule out any argument that holmes
may have been forced to act based on her
relationship with bowani
those text messages are very damning and
very insightful they're showing that
there is fraud because they're
soliciting funds a lot of money frankly
and they know that there are problems
with their testing and when you have a
lab director get on the stand and say
that he was talking about quality
control issues and his warnings were
ignored that's a big problem so far also
brian i haven't seen any evidence that
bowani was the one who was controlling
this was a power couple but the power
behind this couple was definitely
elizabeth holmes now dean of the powers
behind elizabeth holmes belwani has to
be watching holmes trial do you think
what is coming out in the trial is
making bowani's future trial that much
harder for him
i actually think it makes it easier he
gets to see
what holes maybe he can poke you know
the defense attorney and also i imagine
we're going to see him blame elizabeth
holmes just like we're seeing her blame
him
whether or not the jury buys that or not
we'll see so
but i do think it could help him to see
in hindsight what worked and didn't work
for her yeah i think both sides are
going to end up doing the proverbial
throwing each other under the bus
the downside here is often times there's
space enough on that bus for two we'll
continue to follow this case and see how
it progresses thank you both in other
top legal news the trial for an army
veteran accused of breaking into
buildings and landmarks to take daring
photos is delayed so he can get a mental
health evaluation isaac wright traveled
the country scaling buildings and
bridges to take breathtaking photos and
post them on social media under the name
drifter shoots while the photos are
beautiful police in several cities
including cincinnati and new orleans say
wright committed crimes such as burglary
to take these photos wright said he's an
artist and the photography helps with
his post-traumatic stress disorder the
judge in a cincinnati case has ordered a
psychiatric evaluation to determine the
best way to proceed with the case
when we come back testimony in arizona
for the man charged with the murder of
27 year old sasha krauss the latest on
the mennonite murder trial when we come
back
[Music]
welcome back well just when we thought
we were done with robert durst there is
still more to uncover for the infamous
real estate heir his first wise family
announces they want to pursue charges
against his current wife
earlier this month durst was convicted
of murdering his best friend susan
berman the prosecution argued berman was
killed because she had information about
the murder of durst's first wife kathy
though a body has never been found durst
is also accused of that murder now kathy
durham's family hopes to press charges
against durha's wife deborah cheraton a
court document filed tuesday states that
chariton shouldn't be charged with
bigamy alleging cheritan married durst
to assist him in criminal acts and to
conceal his criminal activities the
17-page request includes evidence that
was presented in durst's most recent
trial including a recorded conversation
between chariton and durst in jail
sentencing for der's conviction in
berman's murder is set for october 18th
and in arizona the medical examiner
takes the stand in the trial of a united
states airman accused of murdering a
mennonite woman twenty-two-year-old mark
gooch is accused of kidnapping and
murdering 27-year-old sasha krauss a
member of a new mexico mennonite
community gooch is charged with
first-degree murder kidnapping and theft
he pled not guilty to all charges krause
was last seen shopping for sunday school
supplies in january 2020 about a month
later her body was found near flagstaff
arizona at the time gooch was stationed
at an air force base in phoenix an
autopsy reviewed krauss died of blunt
force trauma and a gunshot wound to the
head a crying lab reported that the
bullet taken from kraus's skull was
fired from a gun that gooch had his
possession cell phone records put gooch
in the area at the suspected time of the
crime on wednesday the prosecution
called the case's medical examiner to
the stand who detailed krause's injury
and her cause of death
she
did have
a skull fracture on
you know kind of
in the region where that that laceration
was there was a fracture
of the skull underneath that area
that fracture
lined up
with
where the bullet had
pushed through or perforated the skull
so i determined the cause of death to be
a gunshot wound
injury of the head and a blunt force
injury of the
head dina rarely does a medical
examiner's testimony connect the murder
to the murderer but does the evidence
come from the fact that the bullet
came from this gun and can be traced
back to gucci's possession does that
create a more incentive that he should
be found guilty
yeah i mean there isn't any dna evidence
on pim so this ballistic evidence and
the connection that the examiner makes
that yes one of the causes of death was
from a bullet it was from a bullet that
he owned his brother has already been
charged with trying to retrieve it after
the announcement of her death is a very
strong piece of evidence for the
prosecution
no terry the medical examiner said that
the cause of death was a gunshot wound
to the head and blunt force trauma to
the head does that indicate anything to
you
it does brian the testimony of a medical
examiner is always critical and
especially if you have a murder case
like this he's saying it's blunt force
trauma to the head a gunshot wound to
the head to me that indicates this was
intentional and it was planned out it is
an execution style murder so when
there's something like that you have to
look at what the motive might have been
and here we already know from evidence
that we've talked about there were texts
about his disdain for the mennonite
religion and if that's the case as an
investigator what i would do is look for
all of that information tie it back to
the motive and that way they have a very
strong case
speaking of strong cases it seems like
something's missing in this case terry
we have as you said those text messages
for disdain for the mennonite community
you have a sunday school teacher not
just someone who is a part of religion
but participates pretty heavily in it
why do you think there are no hate crime
charges in this case
brian that's an excellent point and
maybe if we have some more evidence down
the line about the fact that he had hate
and he had disdain for this religion we
know that he was a former mennonite
person and he practiced that religion
and in fact arizona has a hate crime
statute that basically says if there's
any evidence that the crime was based on
the hate of your identity and the fact
that you are part of that religion is
part of your identity exactly well
obviously those charges aren't here but
we'll continue to follow this case and
thank you both and thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you